20th Century Fox has dropped the third official
trailer for the upcoming Deadpool sequel,
which is now officially titled Deadpool 2.
The Not Safe For Work trailer sees the Merc
with a Mouth at his absolute mouthiest as
he meets up with old friends and puts together
a whole new crew for his new adventure.
It's a lot to take in, so take a breath and
follow along as we serve up all the small
details you missed in the trailer for Deadpool
2.
Protect your neck
While the early teasers for Deadpool 2 were
cute, this third trailer finally brings all
the goods.
It also offers the first glimpse at the movie's
story.
In the comics, the time-travelling Cable spent
a lot of his time protecting his adopted daughter
Hope, and Deadpool 2 appears to have the mutant
travelling through time to save a mysterious
mutant child from captivity.
It appears that Deadpool will end up captured
at some point in the movie, judging by the
glowing red collar which doesn't seem to be
there just for the sake of kink.
It also looks like the same type of collar
the mutant kid is wearing in one scene.
The trailer initially positions Cable and
Deadpool as enemies, with both heroes adopting
a "punch first, ask questions later" approach.
Could Deadpool end up in the custody of the
same people holding Cable's target captive?
Sick kicks
The original Deadpool was a relatively lean
affair, but after its massive and unprecedented
success, Fox has let the money flow.
From the looks of things, it all ended up
on screen.
The trailer shows off action sequences in
numerous locations, proving that Deadpool
is definitely getting around this time.
There's also a blink-and-you'll miss it shot
of Deadpool in a fight at a strip club, doing
a front flip and sticking the landing in a
pair of high-heeled boots.
They sort of look like a dominatrix's custom-ordered
pair of Louboutins, which would make sense.
We're not exactly sure why it makes sense,
but for Deadpool, it totally does.
New mutants
A big chunk of the new Deadpool trailer is
spent showing off the new mutants of the X-Force,
but one thing the trailer doesn't serve up
so readily is the identities of all these
obscure X-Force members.
The new trailer makes it clear that Terry
Crews will be portraying Bedlam, a mutant
with the power to send EMP blasts.
In the comics, Domino teamed up with Bedlam
to help him find his brother.
But who's this new kid?
The teddy bear Cable carries suggests a caretaker
mission, and a teaser for the movie from a
year ago contained graffiti Easter eggs referring
to Nathan Summers and Hope.
Now that the full trailer has arrived, it
suggests that Cable is out to protect this
kid, played by the New Zealand-born actor
Julian Dennison.
"I'm here for the kid."
"What?"
"The kid?"
For now, it seems likely that Dennison is
playing the obscure mutant: Thunderbird, a.k.a.
Neal Shaara.
But really, where's Hope?
The trailer also gives a glimpse at Shioli
Kutsuna as a mutant with electrical powers
and distinctive hair.
Our money for this role is on Surge, a.k.a.
Noriko Ashida, who originally appeared in
the comic book series New Mutants in 2004.
The value of a metal man
The Deadpool 2 trailer also features a return
to Xavier's School for Gifted Youngsters.
While most fans caught the glimpse of Colossus,
the real joke is in the background, with a
framed portrait of Karl Marx placed by one
of the school's staircases.
It looks like Xavier is teaching his students
how to harness their powers and seize the
means of production.
Of course, the trailer also features an instant-classic
shot of Deadpool commandeering Professor X's
wheelchair.
It: Chapter 1.5
We already knew all about Zazie Beetz taking
on the role of Domino as a part of Deadpool
and Cable's X-Force, but we had no idea that
Pennywise was hiding out on set.
The full Deadpool 2 trailer features our best
look yet at It actor Bill Skarsgård as an
unnamed member of the X-Force.
Some guesses have him pegged as being Rictor,
a mutant who once had a serious grudge against
Cable due to believing the time traveler had
killed his father.
Additionally, Rictor is in a relationship
with the mutant Shatterstar, a sword-wielding
mutant who can be seen standing behind Deadpool
in one shot.
Couching a socially progressive message in
a movie full of four-letter-words and decapitations
is exactly the sort of thing Deadpool would
do.
Purity schmurity
While the trailer doesn't get too into details
on the movie's antagonists, it does look like
a group of bad guys are set on keeping humans
and mutants segregated.
You can see Domino delivering the beatdown
to an enemy in a room wallpapered with propaganda
posters, with slogans like "Purity, Humanity,
Infinity" on the walls.
Whatever the bad guys are up to exactly, we
wouldn't be surprised if it was the start
of something bigger.
After all, X-Force is going to need some kind
of cause to fight, and human-mutant separatists
sound like just the ticket.
We'll call you
At some point, Cable and Deadpool team up
to try and put a team together, and what better
way than headshots and auditions?
Deadpool pages through the resumes of a whole
gaggle of mutant mercenary hopefuls, with
the trailer pausing pointedly on a photo of
one Rob Delaney as "Peter."
Who?
Delaney is a comedian best known for his super-popular
Twitter account and the television series
Catastrophe.
Whether or not Delaney will actually play
a part in the movie, we're not quite sure.
He could be Pete Wisdom, another occasional
ally of the X-Men who can throw energy blades
from his fingers.
In the comics, Pete helps Bedlam hone his
powers and teaches him martial arts.
We know one thing for sure, though — we
definitely want to see the rest of those headshots.
This iteration of the X-Force is off-the-wall
enough already — the "rejected" pile for
this project must really be something else.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!